من بيروت ينضم الينا العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
عميد الياس حنا ما اهميه هذا الاختراق
باستعاده روبوتين فيما لو سبت بالنسبه
للطرف الاوكراني
ال سي اذا اخذنا الخط الجبهه 900 كيلو متر
المركز الاساسي للهجوم هو من زبالوجيا
اوريكيف وبالتالي روبوتين اذا روبوتينو
استطاع الجيش الاوكراني ان يصل اليها فاذا
هو انتقل من المنطقه الرماديه الى الخط
الدفاع الاول وبالتالي كلما تقدم كلما
اصبحت الدفاعات الروسيه اقل دفاعا مما
كانت عليه ولكن هذه الطريقه تفتح باتجاه
توك ماك اذا نظرنا الى الخريطه مدينه
توكماك هي محور اساسي الذي يذهب باتجاه
الشرق يذهب باتجاه الغرب وباتجاه ميليتو
بول وهي مهمه جدا ولكن لماذا روبوتينو ال
سي هذا ياخذنا الى الطلب الامريكي من
الجيش الاوكراني ان يركز فعلا كامل قوته
على هذه المنطقه لاحداث الخرق وبالتالي
الدخول في العمق الدفاع روسيا ويبدو انه
بدا هذا الامر بالتالي هذا مرتبط فيما لو
حدث بالفعل هذا الاختراق لان الطرف الروسي
ينفي هذا مرتبط الى حد بعيد
بتوصيات النيتو لاوكرانيا باعاده ضبط
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه في الهجوم المضاد
اليس كذلك
بالطبع النيتو مع رئيس الاركان
البريطانيا اجتمعا مع رئيس
الاوكرانيه على الحدود مع بولندا وبالتالي
تم الاتفاق على هذا الامر ولكن ال سي
عندما تطالب امريكا القوات الاوكرانيه
انطاقاتل بالقتال المشترك للاسلحه ولا
تعطي اوكرانيا الاسلحه الذي ما هذا الامر
لا يمكن تحقيقه ولكن يبدو ان التركيز
الاساسي سوف يكون باتجاه روبوتينو وتوك
مارك ولكن يبقى توك ماك مدينه كبيره محصنه
مدينه كبيره محصنه فهل الامكانيات الجيش
الاوكراني قادره للوصول الى هذه المناطق
طيب هذه الاستراتيجيه الجديده عميد الياس
كيف من شانها ايضا ان تؤثر على الخطط
الروسيه الميدانيه
هي جيده في مكان وسيئه في مكان اخر اذا
الجيش الاوكراني ركز على مكان واحد هذا
الامر قد يعني ان القوات الروسيه قد تتجمع
في هذا المكان وتترك باقي المناطق وهذا
يصعب العمليه العسكريه على القوات
الاوكرانيه وهذا ما يقول عنه الرئيسكي
يعني اذا قتلنا في مكان
وتركنا الامكنه الاخرى سيحقق الجيش الروسي
انتصارات معينه وهذا ما يحدث فعلا ال سي
في الشرق في كوبيانسك اشكرك جزيل الشكر
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ليسحنى ضيفنا
من بيروت